we're almost at the end of the year
we're almost at the end of the show
that's right we've had some amazing
guests this year Kelly Clarkson Simone
BS J Pharaoh as Kevin Hart yeah yeah um
but you know who I missed from last year
uh John Ham Kevin Bacon Holly be you
just you saying famous people with food
names kind OFA rice that was a good
that's a good one but no even better
remember this I still love con yeah I
get to meet the actual keen and Cal like
I'm so funny might make be cracking up
you heard of Kevin Hart
before you probably know this C but I
never even knew Kevin har until you told
me this this is this is Kevin Hart here
he keep calling me kale I
know kale ke wasn't that funny kale he
was adorable he was adorable I love how
he say the word cone he he say cone yeah
yeah you like that I'm be honest with
you I didn't think the kid was adorable
okay I didn't yep I didn't I didn't
think he was adorable at all I really
feel like that kid needs to be humbled
okay yes all right well he's a year
older now so maybe he's changed let's
find out here he is the corn kid hi Keen
h k oh
God hey what in the whoa he's changed a
little bit yeah a little it must have
put some testosterone in his comb yeah
very good I want to say Mr corn kid you
you look all grown up you got facial
hair and everything huh I just started
puberty okay good congratulations what
what else You' been up to you still in
the cone M cone's okay I guess but you
know what I'm really into
PA what did you I'm sorry say what what
you say again porn is he talking about
porn did you say you talking about porn
right I believe he is oh you bet your
ass I'm talking about paone okay it
paone is a beautiful thing it's way
better than con uhhuh there's all types
of P stepmom pone interracial pone
Japanese cartoon pone cream pone oh
I let's get him out of here before he
gets us cancer yeah yeah yeah get out I
don't have any passants on your
perverted ass up off the screen get your
perverted happy New Year
Con